lors du premier tour des élections
municipales 2020 le 15 mars dernier
nelly duthu est arrivé en première
position
la maire sortante est suivi de près par
le conseiller municipal d'opposition
nicolas dainville en troisième position
jean-yves blé ancien premier adjoint et
membre d'un groupe au sein de la
majorité sortante
ces trois listes ont maintenu leur
candidature pour le second tour le 28
juin prochain
la verrière est une commune historique
de la ville nouvelle de saint quentin en
yvelines avec plus de 6000 habitants une
ville touchée par des problématiques
sociales un taux de chômage de 16 % le
taux de pauvreté atteint près de 24%
l'insertion et l'emploi des sujets
d'autant plus important après la crise
sanitaire du coc vie de 10,9 et le choc
économique des thématiques en lien aussi
avec l'éducation et la scolarité dès le
plus jeune âge
la lutte contre l'incivilité et la
relation entre les forces de sécurité
les quartiers populaires un sujet prise
en compte par les candidats
la verrière touchés par le phénomène de
désert médical le manque de médecins et
de professionnels de santé sur la
commune pose des difficultés d'accès aux
soins
enjeu crucial par rapport à la pandémie
du coronavirus des projets d'aménagement
sur la ville d'abord la rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'étang ce sujet qui
divise
d'un côté une rénovation sur les
bâtiments existants de l'autre une
destruction reconstruction partielle de
certains immeubles de projets qui
peuvent bénéficier des fonds de l'
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
autres quartiers de la verrière orly
parc concerné par plusieurs projets
d'aménagement
autre projet d'urbanisation d'envergure
intercommunale menée conjointement avec
saint quentin en yvelines
le projet urbain gare bécane 1800
logements une zone d'activité économique
et un pôle de transport multimodal
juste à côté le carrefour de la malle me
donne attendu pour 2026 le réaménagement
du site prévoit un enfouissement la
verrière maurepas et coignières
actuellement séparés par la nationale 10
seront ainsi reliés